fasciné par versailles c'est une folie
j'aurais aimé 0 18e siècle je raconte
même pas quoi moi j'aurais été dans
l'eurozone se contentent personnes
sociale et en tant que femme je rate est
vachement d'âge pour c'est vraiment un
truc qui manque
non j'ai pas et j'ai pas beaucoup
beaucoup de tendresse pour versailles
mais c'est symbolique quoi voir
controversé g que de les versions drame
en jeu du côté du peuple bête je suis
super pour guillotine mais super tour
c'est une question de fâches taiso
l'école mais ça n'empêche que c'est un
beau livre c'est un choix de personnages
c'est vrai que c'est marrant les
intrigues à la course et tout ça et bien
quoi mais je le sens un peu bizarre
qu'on entend ça se livre aussi cette
manière que vous avez de décrire le
monde est ce pour vous une manière de
vous révolter contre le monde ne me
ravit c'est peut-être pas je sais pas ce
qui est chez vous et que dénonciation
scolaire de dénonciation
ce que je vois autour de moi où est ce
que les gens sont c'est normal moyenne
colère bercy alors tout ce que vous
faites est impossible comment ça se
passe bien sûr ce pressing pas une
couleur c'est un peu naïve c'est un peu
bête c'est un peu tout ce qu'on veut
mais bien sûr l'année en colère mais
tout ce que vous racontez ici c'est à
dire ce monde de de l'esbrouffe ce monde
de la chanson du rock se montrent des
boîtes à part tout ce monde du sexe
c'est un monde que vous connaissez bien
bah oui forcément c'est un monde
d'hommes je suis dans un monde d'hommes
quel est le rôle des femmes doit mettre
profil quoi donc les rôles des sommes en
gros c'est soirée [ __ ]
non je suis dedans tout le monde a vu
comment moi j'en ressens c'est sûr pas
mâché lâchement et schématique
voilà comment je vois pas chez que c'est
vachement moins subtile que vous dites
vous même que tous vous de quatre
éléments
quel est le rôle des femmes dans ce
monde
amusé mais j'aime les épiques taton
reprendra le pouvoir quelque part on
verra plus tard at-on moi je vous le
pouvoir maintenant corps en tant que
femme et lui aussi en tant que personne
qui est pas né dans les beaux quartiers
je vole pas je vais de mixité de pouvoir
maintenant sexuelle et sociale
je voudrais un truc maintenant
maintenant parce que le médecin se
détériore tout de suite c'est un truc
qui est dangereux tout de suite c'est
vrai on a le vent dans le livre vous
racontez une femme qui est vêtu d'une
manière assez provocante mais se balade
dans le quartier de barbès
la suède est pâle se promène pas encore
là parce pavaner n'est rien juste sapé
comme une fille et bah oui il va se
prendre la barre baisse et c'est une
folie furieuse
il faut essayer de le faire pour
comprendre à quel point c'est vrai quoi
c'est vrai c'est ridicule face et c'est
grotesque et semoy la céréale quoi pour
le faire mais vous êtes bien enfin et
est ce que est ce que vous
ce qui n'est pas dans ce livre quand
même une détestation du désir de l'homme
ouais moi j'ai des comptes à régler je
pense c'est normal je pense pas j'en
vois proche des règles aux apports moi
c'est toute ma vie je suis là dedans je
pense ce sera un peu problématique mais
que j'en passe par là je vois pas où est
le problème parce qu'il ya quand même un
problème à régler avec le désir de
l'homme
moi je crois réel qui encore
complètement omniprésence qui oublie
tout qu'est comme normal tout le temps
qui comme tous ces chiens accéder mais
pourquoi ce désir de l'homme il est bon
il est permanent peut-être mais il est
aussi insolent aussi arrogant aussi
ouais mais je crois que c'est elle
ferait qu'on habille le jeune garçon de
16 ans filles qu'on les envoie dans la
rue un petit peu quand je pense qu'il
comprend va peut-être un peu mieux de
quoi je parle
mais les airelles par contre j'ai pas
rêver je rêve pas quand on a un jour
dans la rue étaient verrouillées donc
combien on sera pas belle c'est pas une
question d'être belle aux poubelles
c'est une question est tangible
une fois qu'on est en jupe c'est la
thèse de bourdieu dans son dernier livre
en fait il ya beaucoup de femmes il ya
17 ans pantalon ou la plupart des femmes
aujourd'hui son pantalon
le jeune femme c'est clair je regarde
une femme qui est en jupe jean beaulieu
puis on est passé sans répondre on est
on est pas à versailles quoi donc c'est
pas un truc délicieux entre gens
charmants
c'est un truc plus brutale qu en
maintenant ses prix c'est plus réel que
sa 70e oui oui mais au 18e à versailles
vous était très très pu être à
versailles
la plupart d'entre nous ont gardé les
cochons que c'était prématuré sur wii
c'était différent quoi moi versailles
j'aurais jamais appris à lire et à
écrire
alors pas trop regretter quoi j chénière
quand même pas les mythes et peut-être
[Musique]